welcome to the heavy spoilers show as
always i'm your host definition aka the
bad out of hell who's always down to
rider holly and this episode we're
breaking down some big game leaks
dc fandom is right around the corner and
we already know that there will be two
games from warner brothers that are
showcased at the event
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing some of the leaks and info
we've managed to gather on gotham nights
and suicide squad killer justice league
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want anything
ruined then i recommend that you turn
off now
if you're still here huge thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
the breakdown
okay so on the 23rd of june we broke the
news that at dc fandom
there would be a suicide squad and
gotham knights game announced
this was because warner brothers had
registered several domains
including batmangothamnites.com
suicidesquadgame.com and suicide squad
killer justiceseek.com
you don't you don't need to be the
riddler to figure those out now
at the time we told everyone to take it
with a pinch of salt
as leaks like that can often turn out to
be untrue
but both titles actually turned out to
be correct as rocksteady announced their
game last week
and gotham knights was dropped along
with the dc fandom schedule
so with confirmation of this we can take
it that the initial leaks have a lot
more validity to them
and we're gonna be going over what we
found out about the game
now firstly suicide squad killer justice
league
well it pretty much gives it away from
its title for years we've cried out for
either a superman or justice league game
from rocksteady
and it does seem that they they were at
least paying a bit of attention to that
now one of the main difficulties that's
often brought up with developing games
around superman or the justice league
is that it's quite difficult to get the
game to feel balanced when
pretty much everyone on the team is an
overpowered being that's able to move at
super speed and fly
sorry batman i'm sure you're good at
making the tease
i'm just kidding you know i love you so
what rocksteady have done
is flip this on its head and place the
characters in the game
but instead of allowing us to play as
them we're now going toe to toe with
them
a lot of people are disappointed that
it's wb montreal behind the batman game
but i think rocksteady made an excellent
trilogy and after spending over a decade
working on it they they likely just want
to try something new
now as for the leaks on the game it will
reportedly drop on playstation 5
xbox series x and pc with a launch
window of late 2021 to early 2022
it will also tie into the batman arkham
universe and this will be the same squad
that we saw teased at the end of arkham
origins
as well as in the movie assault on
arkham so the continuity will be carried
across
and thus the batman that features in the
game will to be linked to the one that's
rumored to appear on gotham knights
similar to arkham knight you will
predominantly be taking the role of one
character
whilst completing certain tasks and
missions with others
this was seen in things like the robin
nightwing and batgill parts of the game
but here the side characters will be
fully integrated into the main
campaign in order to allow you to really
feel like you're taking on the league
the closest comparison i can actually
think of is the upcoming marvel avengers
game
as in that you reportedly play as ms
marvel for the most part
but will have some sections in which you
can switch characters
or you just stand in someone's shoes for
that entire mission
but who exactly is in the squad lineup
well there is of course harley quinn
and according to the league she will
have a multitude of weapons to pull from
harley of course has a signature bat but
in addition to this
she has a powerful hammer and a pair of
pistols for dual wielding
harley can also equip a submachine gun
for long ranged attacks
and she will pretty much be the
all-arounder in the team
next up is deadshot predominantly he's
at his best at long range
and because of this he has wrist mounted
cannons and a sniper rifle
now where he lacks is in the close
quarters combat zone
but if you can keep your distance from
your foes you shouldn't have any trouble
dispatching them
now what this does of course let us know
is that there will be a lot of shooting
in the game
in the arkham series as batman didn't
really use
guns unless they were struck to his car
am i right
you will be facing more enemies from a
distance that
two have the ability to fire back so
expect a lot of
hiding behind cover and popping out to
shoot people for a split second
next up is deathstroke and deathstroke
was of course featured at the end of
arkham origins
there was a squad easter egg that was
dropped there in order to let us know
where things were going
and he was actually the first member
signed up so there is a lot that we can
take from that
as he wasn't in assault on arkham it is
possible that he's been working with
walla behind the scenes
similar to rick flagg wallace could have
potentially recruited him as the leader
and that's why she went to him and asked
him to join the team
this is instead of doing what she
normally does which for some reason i
can't say because
youtube demonetized the last video i did
talking about it but you know what it is
you know you know what they put in their
neck now
deathstroke will reportedly play very
much like batman does in the arkham
games
and he will be extremely stealthy and
good at hand to hand combat
this isn't mentioned in the leaks but
i'd absolutely love to see a rematch
between the two
as by my count batman has beaten him
twice
is it twice origins and night am i right
am i right am i right now in addition to
this
other playable characters are cheetah
king shark
captain boomerang count vertigo and
enchantress
these are the more sort of side
characters that you won't spend too much
time with
but they're all pretty balanced with
king shark being a hulk-like character
and cheetah being a fast-moving stealthy
combatant meanwhile the justice league
roster is made up of batman
superman wonder woman flash green latin
martian manhunter shazam and hawk girl
this is a really interesting lineup
and i can't wait to see how batman
returns after his dramatic departure at
the end of arkham knight
now there was a post on reddit before
the game was announced from a user that
said that they'd played parts of it
this was deleted quite quickly but
website nerd stash managed to get the
info from it
again take this with a pinch of salt but
as it appeared before the official
announcement
it does add some weight to it the
leakers said that they'd managed to play
against two of the bosses
and that these were wonder woman and
batman they said that batman pretty much
plays exactly like how he did in the
arkham games
predominantly using gadgets and stealth
attacks the users stated that there was
even a predator section
similar to the arkham series however the
game developers had switched things up a
bit
and you were actually the prey this time
with batman hunting you
so big big boss battle that i definitely
think will take a lot of boxes for fans
when discussing wonder woman they said
that she uses her lasso a lot to try and
grab you
and then pulls you in with a sword she's
also able to block a lot of the standard
attacks with a shield
so you have to combo her in order to
break her defenses
and take it down they didn't give much
info on the gameplay beyond that
but it does sound really really
enthralling according to the leaker the
story centers on amanda walla and lex
luther
attempting to create doomsday through
project cadmus in order to eliminate
the justice league wallah plans to
capture the league by sending the squad
in to bring them back alive
in order to await their doom stay
in order to await their doomsday maybe
maybe she should team up with mr freeze
with them puns probably won't happen
though because i heard he's given her
the cold shoulder
we've still got the best ones anyway
that's all of the leaks on the game that
we have so far
and before we jump into gotham knights i
just want to let you know we're giving
away
a free copy of the avengers on any
console of your choice
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below on your thoughts
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of august so make sure you
get involved
i don't know it's not exactly a batman
game but hey you might enjoy it
and if not you can always use it as a
frisbee or as
captain america shield and enjoy it
however you want
now as for gotham night we have some big
announcements on it
so yesterday wb montreal dropped a
cryptic tweet
that had a video in which seemingly
nothing happened it was basically
a circle and a line moving about a
circular grid
however there was a split-second image
that appeared in it
which showed the symbol of an owl this
of course teases the court of owls
who according to the leaks are the big
bad of the game
now in case you don't know the court
were first created by scott snyder
and they were teased in his books before
making their debut in the new 52
snyder dropped little owl statues on
certain pages in the run-up to their
reveal
and this subliminally hinted to the
reader that they were throughout the
city
owls are of course a natural predator of
bats and in the run
we learned that the court of owls had
been lurking in the shadows of gotham
controlling major events since its
creation the court were made up of
high-ranking members of the city
and through their power they'd
controlled elections social events
and all of the politics within gotham
through their assassins the talons
they'd shaped gotham in their image and
batman had to bring them down in order
to stop the city from spiraling into
further darkness
they're excellent enemies for him to
face off against in my opinion
are probably snyder's greatest creation
now the tweet itself pointed to a
twitter account
that had a website link in it upon
clicking this you were
taken to a website which had the text we
have been expecting you
and today's date we didn't want to wait
to see what the announcement was though
and shout outs to bat source for
figuring out that if you change your
computer calendar
then a new message appears which
welcomes you back this is four inputs on
it
and jordan oliman on twitter figured out
that there was going to be a small
teaser every day
leading up to the 21st which is this
friday i know that people call you
jordan
but from now on i'm calling you hackaman
now this could potentially mean that we
get a teaser the day before fandom
which hints at what's going to be in the
game before the big panel
the user also managed to get a
screenshot upon entering the code 761
and this spat out the image of a
wireframe city with a marking on it
we have no idea what this means yet but
it does look like detective vision
and an objective hopefully over the next
couple of days we'll be getting more
information
i'll definitely keep you peeled if
anything pops up now according to the
leaks on this story
we will actually be playing as the
entire bat family this time throughout
the game
similar to the suicide squad entry we'll
get a number of playable characters that
will help to flesh out the story
in case you don't know gotham knight is
actually the title of a comic book run
send it around the bat family and thus
it makes sense for this game to tie into
it too
anyway like i said i'll try and keep you
posted on the updates as we get them
but i hope you enjoyed or deep dive into
it now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the things you've seen and
heard
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our last dc
video which goes over the new
steppenwolf look and more
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best
i've been definition i'll see you next
time take care
peace
[Music]
foreign